anyone who has seen the Star Wars films
and dug into the franchise's vast canon
knows that lightsabers come in a variety
of colors for the most part Jedi wield
sabers that are blue or green colors
that represent the two biggest schools
within the Jedi Order Green is most
commonly chosen by the counselors who
focus on their mental knowledge of the
force blue is most often in the hands of
Jedi guardians who focus on learning
combat and becoming warriors those who
have aligned themselves with the dark
side
mostly Sith Lords flash red lightsabers
of combat and as for purple lightsabers
Mace Windu's violet colored blade was
only introduced to the franchise because
actor samuel l.jackson put in a personal
request to Star Wars creator George
Lucas for a light saber bearing his
favorite color and samuel l.jackson gets
with samuel l.jackson once in the
expanded star wars universe however
there are plenty more colors of
lightsabers to go around although
extremely rare yellow lightsabers are
among them
just like the blue and green lightsabers
the yellow lightsaber is associated with
an important school of thought within
the Jedi Order
that's the Sentinels Star Wars lore
explains that the Sentinels seek a
balance between the counselors and the
Guardians and also wish to educate
themselves on other more practical
aspects of life such as tracking
techniques and espionage unlike some
others in the Jedi Order
sentinels recognize that the force isn't
actually the solution every day a Jedi
uses the force from knowledge and
defense never the yellow lightsaber is
most commonly seen in the jedi temple
guards hikes on the Star Wars animated
series the Clone Wars the temple guards
wheeled double bladed yellow Sabres much
like the dual-ended red weapon Darth
Maul hefted around before it was sliced
in half these lightsabers don't
personally belong to the temple guards
but are instead the property of the
position they hold
additionally there are other rare
sightings of yellow lightsabers
including in the hands of bounty hunter
asajj ventress who apparently found her
lightsaber on the black market Ventress
his blade was identical to those of the
Jedi rather than the more blade like
appearance at the Pyke's wheel
temple guard another Star Wars character
said to have carried a yellow lightsaber
is Anakin Skywalker's Padawan learner
ahsoka tano though George Lucas nixed
the idea of ahsoka using a full-on
yellow saber on Star Wars the Clone Wars
a sokka's mostly green saber was altered
to give off a slightly yellow glow in
essence a lightsabers color reveals
something about its wielder and their
personality
Lucas films Pablo Hidalgo explained that
the Kyber crystals used to make
lightsabers start out colorless the
crystals only take on a collar once they
have been gathered by a Jedi Padawan and
a bond between the crystal and the Jedi
has been formed during creation of the
lightsaber there's even been an instance
in which a yellow saber was made from
unstable red saber crystal when Jaden
Korr purified it and the crystal turned
yellow granting him his third lightsaber
it's been suggested that perhaps the
reason so few yellow sabers are seen in
the era of the Clone Wars is because so
few sentinels still exist in the Jedi
Order with most Jedi either falling into
the category of Consular or guardian
another theory is that because the
sentinels focus so much of their energy
on learning skills outside of the force
they may still exist but they remain so
low on the radar that they rarely have
to whip out their yellow lightsabers
because of their real-world skills their
missions outside of the Jedi Temple
didn't require them to use combats
instead they'd resort to their
real-world knowledge that wouldn't have
required them to show off their
lightsaber skills the Star Wars universe
is ever-expanding with new movies and TV
shows coming even after the Skywalker
saga concludes Lucasfilm is currently
preparing to launch an obi-wan Kenobi
series on the Disney Plus streaming
platform to follow the first live-action
Star Wars show the Mandalorian with any
luck fans may see yellow lightsabers in
all their glory all over the place in
the years to come check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Star Wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]